[Music]
guys i have a good intro for this week
but
i'm going to waste it now that eric's
not here because you're not going to
have any clue what it's about
eric will know maybe some of the
listeners will know hello
and welcome to the pillpod a show where
a bunch of us nerdy ass phds come
together to discuss
critical theory and philosophy we are
indeed the only turn-based philosophy
podcast
on the internet and today i have to
adjust here
we were going to discuss power um and
we're going to do kind of a series on
power that's going to
move into neo-marxism a little bit i
think we're going to get born up for
that what do you guys think about him
love that
i don't know i don't know
and he's surprisingly down to earth for
her galleon
right that's always the critique right
um and yeah in terms of in terms of
knowledge of
the hegel to mark's
move which is not just a move that just
all of a sudden happened of course he's
very knowledgeable in that space um
because we don't want to do no
sophomore marx yeah here yeah so we need
our ex we need our exporter's the kind
of person you basically
is able to unpack like the science of
logic or dos capital like page by page
so if we wanted to talk about that
he would definitely be somebody we
should get on
all right so look forward to borna
almost done his phd on
left left hagel something left hanging
um
and we're going to have to we're going
to use the time zone because he's in
london i think yeah is that in the
united kingdom
dude don't dox him oh [ __ ] yeah
i'll ask him before i put this up um so
we had this
great episode set up then on a
huge storm hit toronto now
our lights are flickering i got a
warning saying your internet might be
unstable
and eric has been eliminated he's been
killed
struck by lightning we're hoping not for
a total party kill here
um so i had i had given you all roles in
our turn-based philosophy podcast
we have a radical left inquisitor
paladin
matt mcmanus
back from the wars back from the wars
with the alt-right looking for an
adventure
um eric was the circle of signs druid
returning from the mountain to warn us
of impending ecological collapse like
zarathustra nice
and victor you are hostage negotiator
politics guy of the bard class
because you have a rich sexy voice and
very high charisma
that's funny wait pills what does that
make you then i'm the gm
yeah what did you have oh okay you're
gonna you're gonna
get tied up in my state apparatus and
i'm going to do whatever i want to you
now wait a second here i thought we were
anti-turn based
that episode never came out if you
remember
oh right okay so if you didn't hear us
last week it's because
we released our first patreon only
episode
and we have patreons
yeah which is patrons oh patrons sorry
yeah when we
when we recorded the episode we had no
patrons and now we do have patrons
so you're still going to get at least
well probably four three times a month
free content here
and then the other half of that's gonna
be behind the patreon wall if this is
your thing if it's not don't worry about
it if you're happy with
the scraps that you are being given um
they're giving good stuff i think so
we're gonna we're gonna bounce back and
forth between there and here
and and as a and as a big podcast
listener i can say that i'm i've i've
never been a patron
uh so i respect all people who just want
free things because i want free things
but for those of you who are
patrons that's awesome and we're gonna
say the stuff on patreon that we
that are are we doing patreon okay sorry
patreon
we're going to say the things on the
patreon that our bosses can't hear that
our employers will never find out about
so
if that's an incentive there you go
yeah we can really let loose on those
patreon episodes
speaking of listeners are you guys
interested in hearing where our
listeners are from because i could i
could open up the stats here
i'd love to know where they're from and
how many how many we haven't had in the
last couple episodes oh they're going up
they're like each one kind of goes up as
a as another one
goes up so if we do country breakdown i
can even do
like states breakdown but oh wow this is
cool
tell us some cool tell some questions
especially because we were [ __ ] on
the south
last week um yeah i'm curious do we have
a lot of any southern listeners for that
episode
i actually got a response from a
southern listener who was
let's say let's say and he was he's
actually a person an acquaintance that
in my personal life so he listened to it
and he mostly agreed with it sounded
like but he also said that
we were kind of buying into a media
narrative
about the the mainstream media
presenting the south
constantly as a race war when when he
says
when you live here it doesn't actually
feel like that so
i mean that's good critique of a
critical theory podcast we can critique
ourselves
yes most of what we know about the south
or at least i could speak for myself
what i know about the south comes from
the news
and the elections and you know most of
what you hear about the south is oh yeah
they elected another pedophile
or or spread over a teacher's union or
something like that
or just one or one immigrants to go away
to be fair to alabama they didn't
actually elect roy moore they almost
elected roy moore
they were considering it carefully
deeply
considering but i will also say that
perhaps the divide is more accurately
like a rural urban divide because i
think like
maybe this is what your listener was
pointing to that obviously like if
you're in a southern city
like it's not at all what we're
describing right if you're in dallas i
mean here and he's specifically
from houston now but he also lived in uh
one of the carolinas for a while so
i mean he's got much more personal
experience for us but he said
the thing we got most right was the
renegade
and the reason that they're so
distrustful of government
um and you know building bomb shelters
or whatever is because they think the
north is going to come back they're on
their way back
it's just a matter of time that's fun
that's pretty funny that would have been
the thing that maybe i would have
expected to not be true
yeah no i have a buddy of mine from um
texas actually he was in my phd program
uh very smart guy i should say but yeah
he used to say the same thing right
if you go into like rural texas his
family um
you know is dark skinned right you know
people will look at you funny and like
there's a lot of animosity but he said
the weird thing is people in houston
almost over compensate for the image
texas has internationally
by being like ultra ultra liberal right
like
that's something victor uh the other
victor
said last week was they have an image
problem
and then some people try to overcode
that
image problem by being extra extra
saccharine
and the revisionist history about the
civil war yeah
okay so we don't hate the south just
stop electing no i love the south africa
the people that you
constantly elect so what other fee have
you gotten any other like uh feedback
from from
about that episode or no uh no that was
i
well i don't always check the comments
that we get but anyway
uh looking at the stats since you're
talking about it i can just click on
here i'll click on us here
like what is the majority in terms of
country countries for sure
the top four are united states canada
australia
uk okay cool as you would expect they're
the
wealthiest english speaking countries
next is uh
germany and next is india which i
well that's interesting there's a lot of
english speakers though there so yeah
there's probably more english speakers
there than there are in canada
and absolutely canada and australia
combined
and probably also more than the united
states maybe probably actually
that's a good point yeah i mean i don't
really know but we could look that up
but i imagine there's got to be
tens of millions of people if you if you
include if you include
if you include english as a second
language spoke what spoken well i
guarantee you india has more english
speakers than well even if you
have a conservative estimate of 10
that's still like
100 million people that's still 130
million or something like that
yeah um germany is our highest
non-majority english country on here
cool netherlands hop up
uh philippines brazil sweden greece that
and then after that it kind of goes into
sub
one percent wow that's interesting oh
that's about it
i think better to promote in mexico
yeah um and then when you break down the
actual
uh our top two which is u.s canada
majority of surprisingly perhaps
california
considering we're a canadian podcast
second is new york but these
go by population illinois texas
michigan um and then
oh we even got some we got one in south
carolina
three in georgia there you go so sorry
for [ __ ] on you but
florida is this is is this all for the
specifically the america podcast
no no this is the entire thing so
they've heard us at one point
in canada we have bc quebec ontario
represented well
not a single listener in saskatchewan or
manitoba
which is fine because we don't want them
anyway but what about alberta oh yeah we
got some alberta
you could probably just oh the maritimes
probably just tune in to here as [ __ ] on
trudeau
yeah maybe uh maritimes only nova scotia
actually okay so why are somebody at dal
we're growing we're small but how many
listeners overall have we do we have so
far like in our in our episodes i mean
it's probably still in the hundreds
right like
we're reaching four thousand total
most episodes are between four or five
hundred
cool that's pretty good that's pretty
cool it's not bad thanks for listening
wherever you're from uh we appreciate it
yes thank you i have a random question
for matt
actually i'm curious because he was
mentioning i got to do better to promote
this podcast in uh in mexico
as you'll be starting to teach uh is
this
will you tell your students that you're
on a podcast or not like
i'm curious about that decision yeah i
know i probably will i mean
the university that i was at in mexico
used to encourage me to
talk to my students about like any kind
of interviews i was doing or books
i mean they didn't have to listen and it
wasn't extra credit or something since
that would be
pretty self-serving but i don't know i
always like tell them like look if
you're interested in whatever it is that
i'm doing or whatever it is that we're
talking about here there are ways to
explore it more thoroughly
so come and support the pell pod yeah
cool
there are some things we say that could
be interpreted
negatively by employers particularly
yeah that's what i mean we'll have to be
careful be more careful on the non
patreon episodes
and once you're once you're even trying
to advance a little bit they kind of go
through your
profile to find out oh is this person
going to get cancelled in like 10 years
yeah we might get cancelled in 10 years
oh god
maybe uh speaking of cancer saying what
do you want to do that
yeah not do not get cancelled but
check out the cancel article or do you
want to talk about the other podcast
first
i think we could talk about the cancel
article first and then move on to that i
mean the two are related but
this is kind of fresh meat all right so
generally today
i mean we had this whole plan that plan
still gonna happen we're
going to talk about foucault versus
neo-marxism versus delize because we've
done some delicious content lately
talking about state and power but since
eric's missing
our druid and he's particularly fond of
foucault
we are instead just going to shoot the
[ __ ] today and hope that you enjoy it
of course we're going to keep with our
theory philosophy but we're going to
look at some more pop culture stuff
because we're trying to fit ourselves
into a niche and the thing about being
an academic or while you're in school
as you still are victim i'm sure you
know you don't know anything that's
going on
like i i resurfaced from your
dissertation research
and like you don't know anything that's
happened in the last three four years
so i'm just learning right now about the
alt-right because i know about jordan
peterson everyone does
of course he's our dad so of course we
know him quite well
but there's all these other guys like
the shapiro
and the the who's the really flamboyant
guy he got canceled
but he used oh uh i don't know how to
put him in
no no i think he's talking about like
that guy with like the the the bleach
blonde hair he was like an editor
is the one and what ended up happening
with him is he made some comments about
how when he was younger
uh like really young 14 15 13. he slept
with a bunch of men and it was a good
formative experience for him
so breitbart was willing to tolerate the
nazi stuff and the racism but
when he seemed to be implicitly
endorsing
homosexual pedophilia that was the line
they drew
yeah yeah totally totally at least at
least we know they have a line who would
have known
it's i wouldn't have thought either but
you know that was where it is
yeah i wouldn't necessarily put them in
the same box as peterson but uh but yeah
sort of uh related issues i think that's
a mistake the reason that we pick on
peterson and he's never gonna listen to
this obviously
but the reason we feel like he's our
rival
is because first of all he's an academic
second of all
he's from toronto and third
this is our jewish song so if we want to
put it in psychoanalytic terms we want
to separate him from his object of
desire because we actually have the same
object of desire which is
being like recognized for your
intellectual work except we think his
intellectual work is [ __ ]
yet he's getting recognized for it so
it's
we're taking pleasure in in
trying to violate his his experience
with his own object of desire
there's our there's our viewers
yeah he's uh he's been he's been pretty
mute for a while though of course
comas do that yeah you must have heard
about how sick he got and uh he was in
russia for a while i think he actually
just went on his daughter's podcast he's
in
serbia yeah he's in serbia that's it
yeah
this is uh he has actually written
something recently i was going to say he
published an op-ed in the national post
talking about um the controversy over
that chemistry teacher at brock
university i'm not sure if you heard
about that
no i don't think i did maybe you could
uh uh so
summarize this professor released an
article uh and it included some
basically like hits against cancel
culture
and the way it was that um the
university was moving from a quote
meritocracy
to one what was all about trying to
include i like to focus on diversity and
so on and so forth
uh and brock basically said you know we
don't approve of this
and the journal that had accepted the
article withdrew it right
and it was really odd because the
article was in chemistry and it was just
these kind of random political comments
you know taking shots at pc culture but
long story short of course peterson
wrote the national post about how this
was a disaster and how
you know the vultures were swooping in
you know to try to ruin this guy's
academic career
uh and you know it's reflective of the
broader cultural enemy
and he also compared himself to a greek
prophet which i always really enjoy
you know uh does it you know who
cassandra is right yeah
iliad cassandra yeah no she was a
um prophetess and she basically warned
the trojans that the greeks were hiding
in the trojan horse right
and nobody listened to her because she'd
been cursed to utter the truth about the
future and have no one listen
uh by the gods and of course you know
troy fowle and there's all that kind of
stuff right
uh but yeah i know peterson has reached
the point now where he's comparing
himself to peoples and
to people and myth which might be
slightly better than him comparing
himself to christian prophets i don't
really know
i shouted in the wilderness and you did
not hear me
so did this so this this chemistry
professor so he had to withdraw all that
stuff
yeah the journal basically said that
they were going to withdraw the article
because that wasn't up to their
standards and it also included
needless politicization uh what was
supposed to be uh chemistry piece right
uh
right which is kind of interesting it's
kind of funny that he did that yeah
i mean it was to a chemistry journal he
did
yeah chemistry but the examples he used
or something were like shots at pc
culture
yeah he just included some random
comments within the
text that was supposed to be about uh
some topics in chemistry
saying things like well the university
used to be meritocratic but it's no
longer now they all focus on diversity
hirings
uh and free speech is increasingly
suppressed
i mean the guy is fairly old and
crotchety uh from the sense that i got
um
i don't know what's going to happen to
him my understanding is that he hasn't
faced any kind of actual reprimand from
his
from his work beyond um a couple of the
officials saying like we don't consider
this behavior
acceptable and i don't imagine he will
actually face any more serious reprimand
that that and
you know having his article get
cancelled but i mean that's the thing
right they scream bloody murder and
actually nothing
substantial happens to these people
almost ever
it's just like people calling you names
on twitter and obscure canadian podcasts
some people's some people do end up like
maybe this guy nothing happened to him
but some people i guess have been like
fired for various things
but it's not like a terrible it's not
like endemic like uh
very common no i mean i i'm not
particularly fond of world culture right
for a lot of reasons and i do think that
there's a problem with it's over
prevalence at the university
i also do think that these commentators
who suggest that it's somehow
a moral threat to western civilization
uh aren't just overstating
uh they're kind of that's exactly right
almost overstating it to the point of
comedy
right like where you think like yeah
this is you know
a minuscule little problem that you've
somehow transformed into something
tantamount to the emergence of fascism
or
or soviet communism or whatever right
and it's almost conspiracy brain right
yeah
well to some extent it almost seems like
both both sides
like both extremes right the ones who
think it's like a huge problem maybe
like the most woke
like uh they kind of use each other to
sustain their own sort of fantasy
oppositional fantasy that they're like
fighting the good fight so i think both
have an interest in making the problem
seem worse to some extent
for their own sort of jewy sons to bring
it back to lacan
in a way yeah i think you're exactly
right i mean born i could talk a bit
more about this next week right but
there certainly is a kind of dialectical
antagonism between the two
uh although in this case it's much more
of a conscious dialectic right where one
side deliberately tries to antagonize
and flame the other to rile up attention
for themselves
and then the other side responds in kind
right yeah for sure actually maybe
that's a good time i could bring up this
this harper's letter on justice and open
debate
yeah rather than speaking in
generalities we have this uh
open letter signed by presumably
important people and what happened there
uh yeah so like this letter was released
and signed by a bunch of pretty
famous authors and academics including
margaret atwood noam chomsky
uh i don't know who else is on here like
a bunch of people
some of these names i don't recognize
because they're like literature i don't
know francis fukuyama malcolm gladwell
oh yeah jk rowling gloria is pissed for
getting countless jk rowling jk rowling
yeah bunch of people so i don't know
it's only three paragraphs
you haven't read it yet though uh no i
haven't but that's a strange assortment
of
uh literati so uh just for me and anyone
else why don't you explain
it from uh the beginning oh gee
do you think i should uh well it's only
three paragraphs do you want me to just
read it and then you can
you can react uh in the moment sure
we've already talked about how you
because you got the second
voice you gotta read it dramatically
richly that's what i was just gonna say
yeah you got that sexy magisterial voice
let's hear it apparently this is the
first i've heard of it but okay
okay so this was published on july 7th
so yesterday uh
from we're recording this on the 8th
right now a letter on justice and open
debate
so it starts our cultural institutions
are facing a moment of trial
powerful protests for racial and social
justice are leading to overdue demands
for police reform
along with wider calls for greater
equality and inclusion across our
society
not least in higher education journalism
philanthropy and the arts
but this needed reckoning has also
intensified a new set of moral attitudes
and political commitments
that tend to weaken our norms of open
debate and toleration of differences
in favor of ideological conformity so
what i've heard
so far is we're in touch but don't worry
we're really out of touch
okay sorry as we applaud the first
development
we also raise our voices against the
second the forces of illiberalism are
gaining strength throughout the world
and have a powerful ally in donald trump
who represents a real threat to
democracy
but resistance must not be allowed to
harden into its own brand of dogma or
coercion
which right-wing demagogues are already
exploiting the democratic inclusion we
want
can be achieved only if we speak out
against the intolerant climate
that is set in on all sides the free
exchange of information and ideas
the lifeblood of a liberal society is
daily becoming
more constricted well we have come well
we have come to expect this on the
radical right
sensoriousness is also spreading more
widely in our culture
an intolerance of opposing views a vogue
for public shaming and ostracism
and the tendency the tendency to
dissolve
complex polish policy issues into a
blinding moral certainly just
just a bit like
when this is just a a refrain
of you hear all these words in this
order
all the time is this people's experience
actually changing or is it just because
these people are on twitter
all day i think you're right i think i
think you're right that being on twitter
certainly
uh it it it like intensifies and
magnifies the experience i mean it makes
things seem
worse than there but i also think that
there is like there has been some sort
of
a shift as well i think it's a bit of
both
i don't know did you experience this in
like your life
no i mean in academia like i mean i hang
around with academics but i mean
probably not with my non-academic
friends too much
i don't know matt what do you think yeah
i was gonna say i think one of the
reasons why
this is assumed so much attention
recently is the stakes are a lot higher
for some of these people right
unlike public broadcasters or even
academia directly academia i should say
uh people like twitter like our forums
like twitter our facebook
create their own rules and they respond
to public pressure right so if you are
able to actually create a campaign that
gets enough momentum to cancel someone
that can have a serious financial impact
on them as well as an impact on their
ability to disseminate
information right i mean if you want a
good example this milo yiannopoulos
is one that i actually took some
satisfaction of uh because he was voted
off a lot of these mediums
and now he's complaining that he's
basically penniless right he lost all of
his sources of income
and to be fair he deserved that for
being a racist nazi right but
you know i can understand why people are
concerned about this since the stakes
are really high for a lot of them
do do i think that this is a big problem
beyond
the kind of digital public sphere let's
call it that uh
yeah i mean every stereotype usually has
some basis in truth right and if you
spend enough time in academia
of course you'll meet people who kind of
configure to
a lot of these kinds of liberal and
right-wing stereotypes right um
i knew when i was doing my phd someone
uh who would take
issue uh if you're a white dude
listening to rap
for example right and i remember i was
telling her about how i was listening to
kendrick lamar or something she's like
well you have no experience with that
i'm like oh really
i'm not a you know a dude you know
selling crack in new york city and you
know
come on hey l.a l.a yeah in l.a yeah
but at least we know you listen to
kendrick lamar so it's confirmation
that you're not racist because those
things are incompatible hey no he's
fantastic right
yeah absolutely no no but you know see
if you look hard enough you can find
these kind of stereotypes and
i do definitely think that there's
sometimes pressure to conform to a
certain kind of ultra woke
expectation uh did i ever feel
like i wasn't able to speak my mind in
an academic setting
i would say no right certainly not
directly right um
and would i feel like i would not be
able to speak my mind if i were
a tenured professor like a lot of the
people who speak most vehemently on this
issue are
no i don't think so right uh and i think
one of the ironies is people like jordan
peterson or stephen hicks
or gad gatsat who constantly come back
to this issue
um far from being silencer amongst the
most vocal people in the entire world
all right um so i do think it's
a problem no i'm saying i do think it's
a problem and something that we should
address and i also think it has
a debilitating impact on the left
because a lot of people
fixate on the kind of most annoying
features of left-wing activism
and they're turned off by it right but i
also don't think it's nearly as big a
problem
as a lot of these right-wing individuals
trying to make it out to be
my thought about this has to do with
solicitation of opinions because
if if i'm in an academic environment and
my opinion is
unsolicited then there's no requirement
for me to give it but it sounds like
what these people are saying is i should
be able to give
my opinion on all things at all times
regardless of who's present
and when you take that into the internet
it just doesn't make sense because
on twitter that room is everybody but to
me this really reeks of
you know their moral indignation that
people are not soliciting
their opinions anymore and how dare
someone
come to question my judgment
i'll have you know i am esteemed member
of the intelligentsia
yeah did we just lose we just lost
victor yeah i was gonna say i think he
just disappeared
well we were afraid this was gonna
happen that this storm
this storm would uh knock out our
communications
um but yeah like well let's carry on for
a couple minutes and then
hopefully he'll come back i mean we can
i can keep reading the article because i
just opened it while he was
while he was talking but i mean yeah i i
consider this to be a little bit silly
in the sense that
they just assume that their opinion has
to be heard all the time by all people
whereas seriously it looks like like
materially and physically a lot of
people have been
minorities particularly have been barred
entry
from these spaces intentionally and
that's not at all what's happening this
isn't like the reverse
of that it might be an overcompensation
it might be a pendulum swing
but you know i really see this as a
a classist document and it's not a class
is in like uh
bourgeoisie proletariat but this
literati
class that is upset
that people are in their space and that
people are
telling them to control their volume i
guess yeah
i mean and there's often a kind of
implicit conservative bias because a lot
of these people don't like to admit
their own political propensities
when it comes to a lot of these debates
about you know political correctness in
the curricula right
and there's this argument that wow you
know we need to teach people
about you know the fundamental text of
western civilization and if we don't do
that they're not getting an education
that's worthy of the name
and my kind of response to that is well
why do you think that right i mean
you could learn a great deal from
confucius that you would also get in
aristotle but if you decide to swap out
aristotle for confucius you also get the
added benefit of having students who
have some familiarity with chinese
philosophy now
right and you can compliment that by
making sure that they read plato so they
have some familiarity with greek
philosophy also right
you know if you're looking at 20th
century literature and you swap out
george orwell for chinua achebe right
things fall apart
again you know would you be losing
something you know certainly people
everyone should read your while but then
everyone should also read the cepe as
well
right and people don't really have a lot
of good arguments against this
except to cry foul and then
often try to implicitly imply that
wow these works from other cultures
are substandard they're just not as good
uh as what we
don't even think that's what this
letter's saying though the letter on uh
justice and open debate to me it just
looks if you scan the list of names at
the bottom
these are just all right well we need
you to finish
we need you to finish reading but um
okay i'd like to finish
we were talking about your opinions
being
solicited and these people
on this list it looks like to me have
forever had their opinions solicited
now you're you're you're probably okay
okay here we go i think are you guys
these are the people whose opinions are
suddenly not being solicited and they
tend to be you know
boomer boomer famous people yeah i
just want to finish up by saying the
reason i brought up curriculum and kind
of what appears on them
uh on the curricula right uh it's
because it's indicator the more general
mindset these people have
right which is that oftentimes they try
to
present their concern as just being
about freedom of speech and trying to
make sure that every side is heard
and a lot of the authors in this letter
i think that's exactly what they're
trying to do and i commend them for that
right
uh but for many people who book this
kind of rhetoric what they're trying to
do is push an implicitly conservative
agenda
usually one that has very
problematic elements uh maybe not like
what i just talked maybe not
conservative but just
center you know normative they want to
maintain
normalcy and trump freaks everybody out
but i think
yeah i think matt's right though that
there is that there are some people who
are using and that's what makes it
difficult to
maybe you guys were talking about this
when my internet cut out but like that's
sort of what makes it difficult to like
fully agree because you know that some
people are using this sort of like
anti-wokeness as a cover to really like
push through their more conservative
uh like agendas a little bit yeah yeah
yeah i think that's exactly right right
and the thing is i have no problem with
freedom of speech and freedom of
expression and
trying to allow as much dialogue and as
many opinions as possible right and
i think that's a very progressive
standpoint and i do find it really
frustrating
that some on the political left don't
actually share that opinion right
and i think it's damaging to progressive
causes and not only is it damaging but
it paints us all with a negative brush
right yeah and
would you have to extricate yourself
from yeah into saying that
i also don't think that a lot of the
people who push for this kind
of rhetoric are all that interested in
freedom of speech and dialogue for its
own sake
rather they use these as a cover to try
to advance their own kind of agenda
because if they were put in positions of
authority uh they would probably try
their best
as best they could to marginalize or
silence a lot of the voces
that opposed which is always this thing
like uh
sorry what's it called they call they
said it in the article i'm pretty sure
western culture
this amalgam of you know the the best
and brightest that the world has ever
produced
this is the thing we have to defend it's
under threat
like come on right yeah i mean i think
so actually maybe i should read a little
bit more here because they i think
they they start they start getting more
specific about the kind of consequences
they're worried about okay so they say
here
um okay we uphold the value of robust
and even caustic counter speech from all
quarters
but it is now all too common to hear
calls for swift and severe retribution
in response in response to perceived
transgressions of speech and thought
more troubling still institutional
leaders in a spirit of panicked
damage control are delivering hasty and
disproportionate punishments
instead of considered reforms editors
are fired for running controversial
pieces
books are withdrawn for alleged
inauthenticity journalists are barred
from writing on certain topics
professors are investigated for quoting
works of literature in class
a researcher is fired for circulating a
peer-reviewed academic study
and the heads of organizations are
ousted for what are sometimes just
clumsy mistakes whatever the arguments
around each particular incident
the result has been to steadily narrow
the boundaries of what can be said
without the threat of repop reprisal
we are already paying the price in
greater risk aversion among writers
artists
you mean for their livelihoods if they
depart from the consensus
or even lack insufficient or even lack
sufficient zeal in agreement
man this is just the baldest declaration
of self-interest i'm afraid that my book
deal is in jeopardy so
you all have to change although not to
be just
too contrarian here there's definitely
something to that term disproportionate
response in some cases at least
probably not to any of these people but
for those with less of a platform to
defend themselves
saying something they probably didn't
mean in context mistake in fact i would
say that that gets to the core of like
my biggest problem with um so-called
cancel culture
is like that that it's sometimes in like
it's more extreme forms
is overly preoccupied with i guess what
i would maybe call a logic of
retribution punitive
right like about which i don't like i
just don't agree with retribution
on any side that's why like this could
be a totally different kind of
conversation i'm basically a prison
abolitionist
like so i don't believe in retribution
as like a logic for
making society better in any circles so
i don't think that like firing somebody
obviously it's a different situation
completely like i don't want to get in
the whole thing about prison abolition
but like
just in general i don't agree with that
logic of punishment
um for like things that are
disproportionate i think that like if we
want to make
people buy into ideas uh sort of a
mindset of retribution is the wrong way
to go so yeah when people get fired or
silenced or
whatever yes it's not like some criminal
penalty but it still seems
like a disproportionate uh penalty for
something that is like as you said pills
could be
a pretty small mistake i mean what comes
to mind in canada is
i mean this might have been a bigger
mistake i actually haven't followed up
on the story but there's
this canadian journalist wendy mesley i
don't know if you guys heard about this
cbc journalist apparently she like used
the n-word during a meeting don't know
i don't know if it's true to like i
don't know if it was true that they
quote that she quoted
she said she was quoting something and
yeah like that's a mistake shouldn't do
that
i think it was uh martin luther king's
letter from birmingham jail wasn't it it
was something like that
yeah it was something like you shouldn't
repeat the word whatever but like to
you know a lot of people were calling
for her to be fired and i think i
actually listened to
another canadian podcast that's about
media criticism canada land
i don't know if you guys know it are
familiar jesse brown yeah yeah he uh he
uh he had this this uh journalist
desmond cole
who's like a well-known uh i guess you
could say a little bit on the more woke
side
and uh he was on discussing what they in
that podcast instead of calling it
cancel culture uh desmond cole was
arguing to rename it
consequence culture and he was sort of
arguing well yes there are consequences
for doing things
but in the in that episode he was i in
my opinion
uh a little bit unreasonable and was
calling wendy mesley like a racist
disgrace and
you know and and jesse brown the host
was asking him well you know what is if
if she just made a mistake in this one
incident you know
like we should talk about what the
proportionate response is and he was
kind of like well why is it my job as a
black person to like decide these things
and like
she's a racist disgrace like end of
story yeah he said this on the podcast
and i was just like okay that's like a
little bit obviously we don't know
what was said but proportional
punishment definitely has to take
context
into account especially if she's quoting
dr king yeah so i actually haven't
followed up on the wendy mesley story so
i don't know if
if it came out that it was actually
worse but she was initially saying that
it was
really just something that she was
quoting she was quoting someone else
during a meeting
and uh there was there was a person of
color in the meeting who took
great offense and and it became like a
larger controversy
and i don't know if she's if she's gonna
get fired but that was sort of what a
lot of people
were calling for yeah well i mean
the the thing that this article entirely
leaves
out is that this is not like state
infringement on the right
their freedom of speech really these are
just like these are brands
journals publishers news networks
schools you know seeking
the response that's correct in the eyes
of their
consumers so ultimately these these
signatories are complaining about
market decisions right but the only
thing you can really do to curb
market decisions is legislate so i guess
the
the subtext of this letter is that the
state protect them from their own
employers
actually that that's what i wanted to
say and it's where i think actually this
becomes most problematic because
i don't like the idea uh private and
particularly market actors
trying to regulate people for behavior
they engage in in their private lives
right
i think that's a really worrying
extension of the kind of logic of the
market
and to interpersonal relations uh and
this isn't to say that i think we should
let people off the hook for making
racist statements
in everyday life uh or that we should
somehow say well just say whatever you
want have a free-for-all no and there
should be no consequences i completely
agree with
who was what was the name of the
journalist you mentioned oh it was
desmond cole
yeah and i think there is a sense that
people have gotten away for too long
we're saying [ __ ] racist stuff
without there being consequence sure
and that's probably why there's a lot of
this be real in state now saying all
that though
i don't like the idea of working for
wherever it happens to be you know
walmart or college or university or you
know
amazon uh saying some things at a bar
one night to a friend of mine having
someone record it
and then all of a sudden i lose my job
because of that because as pills i was
saying
the company is brand conscious and
doesn't want to be associated with that
but i think it's in the important detail
too about the brand consciousness and
absolutely agree with both of you that
but i think like that you know these are
private market actors but i think what
this you know letter actually gets right
is that the brain consciousness is
motivated by fear
right because like the twitter sphere
has has magnified certain voices
so that like a company is just terrified
that there that there's going to be some
like viral twitter
like story about how they you know
defended this employee who was a racist
right and even if it was something
yeah yeah like we're not going to
boycott you for
union busting or having predatory
corporate practices or maximizing
profits over the interests of your
employees
health insurance but if you have a
racist employee no then you're [ __ ]
done right so they're so so there so
their fear
is obviously making them make decisions
that are maybe disproportionate to what
actually happened and that creates
a retributive like kind of outcome
because people are being
disproportionately punished for
something that's motivated really by a
private corporation's fear of being
perceived a certain way
because of the magnified discourse on
twitter
no but i think that's really right vic i
mean a lot of the problem the
problems that we see right now are
consequences of the kind of
magnification
that you see in digital culture right
and the reality is that in many of these
circumstances
uh people are able to dog pile on those
that they oppose
and rally support because it's such an
easy thing to do and the problem with
that of course is that
digital culture doesn't include it
doesn't encourage
looking at context uh of statements or
commentary
uh or books very extensively right
you're able to kind of
take this little one incident uh and
then say look at this this is bad
and then everyone's going to draw the
same kind of opinion from you
as as long as they follow you in some
kind of meaningful way right
exactly and i don't think that's even
necessarily just a left-wing phenomenon
right i think that that's true
on the political right as well uh and
the irony is that people like jordan
peterson or dave rubin or ben shapiro
have all profited from this
as well right when they sit there and
they're like look at these dumb sjws on
campus
see all the stuff that they do right
this is why the left is all crazy and
you should pay attention to them
when i think a lot of us are actually
willing to have a reasonable discussion
with their political opponents
yeah um and are interested in reaching
out
uh it's just so easy to tar an
individual or even entire whole movement
with a single trust by taking one thing
out of context and presenting it as
emblematic
totally um that's what that person is or
what that movement is about it's
frustrating
for me to and and you i think are
speaking to this too matt like both of
us
are kind of pretty like far left but
liberals like ver like both of us i
think are liberals
um and i think that what's frustrating
from our perspective is the way like
this whole
rallying cry against woke culture has
been taken up by people like
ben shapiro and dave rubin and it's like
frustrating because
you see like people online and maybe
even some of our listeners right who
are maybe attracted to the because they
like the critiques of the unreasonable
wokeness
but so then they'll start liking ben
shapiro but what always annoys me about
those podcasts and those episodes is
that all they do is talk about how
annoying the woke left is
but they're never like defending their
own ideas which if you actually go and
talk about like what are dave rubin's
actual ideas they're like back
from like a left-wing liberal
perspective it's like you have bad ideas
and like inst all you're doing is
critiquing the left for like some of
their worst examples where we can agree
that some of the woke left says things
that are unreasonable
but then if we actually turn around and
examine your views dave rubin or your
views ben shapiro like you guys have
shitty views and like
as a left-wing liberal like i want to be
able to talk about
and critique and in some ways i want to
even speak specifically to maybe some of
our
listeners who like those people and like
maybe this could even be a niche part of
a niche for our podcast is like i want
to
you know take some of those people who
are who are who are maybe
um like some of the things that ben
shapiro says
but like bring them laugh let back to
the left and be like you know
like don't you know don't be don't be
seduced by their like
sexy critiques of some of the
unreasonableness on the left
and remember that ideas that are
actually good and make sense
are still on the left yeah i mean contra
points had a really good article or
sorry a video on this recently when she
was
talking about cringe culture right and
she talked about how a lot of these
anti-social justice activists
make an argument from mimicry and
mockery yeah uh
where basically you know you parrot uh
what one or two social justice activists
are saying
uh and then you mock it uh and then
people assume that this is just
emblematic of what people on the left
are
even you know on the far right with
liberals yeah think and they say oh you
know that's just ridiculous
why whatever i have to engage with that
uh and
from paragons of reason and logic this
is a pretty superficial way
of actually trying to argue against your
political opponents
right yeah exactly and you really see
this like when they actually have to
debate someone who knows what they're
talking about right like when jordan
peterson
had to debate slavoj and jesus just
asked him like well who are these
postmodern neo-marxist navy one
it was like oh i don't know they're
everywhere right yeah
where are they it's like well they're
everywhere right they're invisible
they exist in the walls between us
listening and and policing you know what
everyone's saying
and when they say that ben shapiro when
uh he went on that podcast sorry um
bbc a couple years ago right and
somebody asked him like well don't you
think you've contributed to this culture
of hyper partisanship
you know given you've written books like
how to debate a leftist and destroy them
and so on and so forth
you just got up in a huff and left
because you didn't want to have to
bother with that right
matt i'm not accusing you of this
because i just saw you do it and our
listeners did not but you said
paragons of logic and reason with quotes
in your fingers and yeah i i completely
dismiss the right without engaging their
ideas so
uh you guys can you guys can do that you
can be the paladin
i'll be the but we do that because we're
we both do politics you're not you're
you're you didn't study
you didn't spend your phd studying
politically yeah that's where your
interactors have to come from
um but i'm trying to get back to the
article though what did they say we
should do about this because we we've
talked about
we talked about private i just want to
answer jack for one second
and say it's not that i think that there
aren't really intelligent commentators
on the political right
i actually think peterson has some very
smart things to say and i think people
like patrick dineen
or peter lawler were you a brilliant
political theorist you know for what
it's worth
yeah what i'm talking about are what are
sometimes derogatory called logic bros
right people who
invoke reason and logic quite directly
right as terms
uh almost like they're a tantric mantra
and if you just say
i'm reasonable and i'm logical and i'm
reasonable and i'm logical enough
uh that will make it so and my kind of
argument is no
right if you want to be reasonable and
logical then make reasonable and logical
arguments uh i'll let them stand on
their own
they get this from what is obviously
known the intellectual dad web
or actually i'd like to add like i think
the paradigmatic example of this is like
this step on molineux right who you did
debate
and like like i think actually there's i
would recommend to our listeners if
they're interested
like there's a guy on youtube who
recently debated stefan mullen you and i
think he got him he actually like
managed to get stefan molyneux
to like a point to like embarrass
himself a little bit in a way that maybe
in your debate
like there wasn't exactly that
opportunity his name's rationality rules
i don't know if you've heard about this
guy
on youtube i have heard that so he's
destroyed
stefan molyneux no so so actually his
like debate was quite
uh good though like i was impressed with
him and like got
and basically got stephon molyneux to
the point where he was like uh
i don't want to talk about this like
this is boring let's change topics when
he was like beating him clearly
it was pretty funny that is funny so
what is this uh
david brooks matt iglesias harry potter
author what do they say we should do
about it
okay so there's a final short paragraph
uh
so they say um this stifling atmosphere
will ultimately harm the most vital
causes of our time the restriction of
debate whether by a repressive
government or an intolerant society
invariably hurts those who lack power
and makes everyone less capable of
democratic participation
the way to defeat bad ideas is by
exposure argument and persuasion
not by trying to silence or wish them
away we refuse
any false choice between justice and
freedom which cannot exist without
each other as writers we need a culture
that leaves us room
for experimentation risk taking and even
mistakes
we need to preserve that possibility of
good faith disagreement
without dire professional consequences
if we won't defend
uh the very thing on which our work
depends we shouldn't expect the public
or the state to defend it for us
no but they are asking for this state to
defend it for them because
these are the the publishers and the
newspapers and the universities are the
ones that are firing them
that's the only real consequence other
than being called
you know uh a cuck lib or whatever what
what
what are we called by the alt-right soy
boys
is this soy boy's a thing all right so
we're gonna get called a soy boy
you know boo hoo but the people that are
firing them
are these their employers basically or
the people that are buying their
manuscripts
and they're saying we don't want state
intervention but they're asking for
state intervention they want it to be
illegal for you to get fired for saying
something on twitter because all they do
all day is say things on twitter so what
are they well i don't know if they
actually want that they don't say that
yeah
i don't know what they call for that
then what are they doing they're just
giving a manifesto that people are
supposed to retweet
yeah i think they're trying to make an
argument they're trying to contribute to
the to the public dialogue that they so
uh that they're trying to defend here
and say like they're trying to persuade
other people and
maybe persuade like publishers or owners
to not be scared
of of like the twitter mob that might
you know try to talk to the twitter
which is a totally useless thing to do
because you don't i mean this totally
backfired right like the the
the one thing i heard in reaction to
this and even um
uh eric was sort of speaking to it on
our on our on our patreon discord
you can subscribe to the patreon discord
yeah if you if you're if you're if
you're a patron then you can be on the
discord and chat with us
uh he he was saying like i like it there
there's there's there's a reaction uh
that there's
you know it's like he was saying
something like who cares like what these
rich authors think you know like it's
they're hypocrites because some of them
have apparently called other people out
and i've noticed that that's been uh
someone from like one of my colleagues
also sort of repeated something similar
like they're like oh it's funny how like
some of the people on this list have
called other people out themselves and i
was kind of like i don't know like i get
it but
i always find the hypocrisy argument
like kind of weak it's like
you know like who cares if someone's a
hypocrite it's just because al gore
flies a
private jet right like who cares if he's
uh yeah that doesn't say anything about
whether climate change is
we should be worried about it or not
right and it's like just because some of
these people have called people out
says nothing about whether calling
people out is bad or not
i know hypocrite hypocrisy like what
about as it was
one of the thinnest arguments that you
can level against someone right because
you don't have to engage with the
substance of what they're talking about
all you have to do is say well this
person lacks integrity so we can now
ignore everything that they have that's
exactly and
that's some of the reaction that i've
seen on twitter of this uh
like maybe one of the more popular
reactions to this uh statement
yeah i mean i will say this though i
have called that people for hypocrisy
before right because sometimes
it does just become so glaring and so
much fun to observe that of course
almost impossible it's just the
temptation right
of course it is it is nice to to uh to
indulge in some hypocrisy calling
doesn't this feel just like that the
celebrity i take responsibility
video except sort of from the other
direction where it's like
your opinion was is unsolicited
no one asked for it maybe some people
like this i don't know maybe some people
want to i shouldn't say that it's
unsolicited it's certainly unsolicited
from me and i wouldn't be reading it if
you hadn't sent it to me
but yeah well it's unsolicited but like
i don't know why should that matter like
i mean
the twitter is full of unsolicited
opinions like ah that's true maybe it's
a stupid argument
but it's like i i've heard that argument
as well by the way like this unsolicited
thing it's like i don't care i didn't
want to hear what like jk rowling
thought of this and it's like and then
they're saying that on twitter
it's like i didn't care about your
opinion about that either like i don't
know unsolicited
opinions are what twitter is i have a
few
i have a few people i follow on twitter
that are on this list
but they're only on there for like the
eye roll factor
so i noticed uh jonathan hate
oh yeah i don't mind trying he's he's an
eye roller for me
and same with that david brooks
david i think he's a new york times
columnist but they brought him in
because he was the
not trump conservative and then he
writes all this [ __ ] about like refining
his faith after getting divorced and
and stuff like that so very like very
boomer self-help
it's funny sorry younger people though
uh
coleman hughes uh he's a writer for
colette uh he's at columbia and he's his
primary focus is on
um race and racial reparations right
he's probably only about like 22 23 he
signed the letter
oh yeah yeah he's uh yeah he's uh he's
an interesting guy
yeah coleman hughes i think actually
what we should do just to kind of move
the conversation
along a little bit and actually kind of
uh foreground our discussion of power
is what do people think about the kind
of
implicit moral assumption in this which
is that the liberation and debate will
allow
the best arguments to come to the fore
and will enable us to speak truth to
power because
there are these really kind of milsian
undertones
to this piece right which is well if you
allow
a free flow of different arguments in
the marketplace of ideas
the best arguments will ultimately
prevail and individuals be convinced by
them
and society will move forward and this
has always been extremely useful
for people in marginalized communities
and
i should say i'm committed to this ideal
right i think that we need more public
deliberation right and we need better
communication and dialogue and so forth
but i do also think it's really naive
and i know some of the authors there
like noam chomsky
i've written a lot about this right to
assume that if you just allow people to
talk the better argument will always
carry the day
uh and i can't think of any instance in
history where that's happened going back
to somebody like socrates right socrates
had better
arguments uh for why it is that they
shouldn't execute him
uh and the athenians went ahead and did
it anyway
right and i think the same is true today
maybe even more so right
i mean there are all kinds of instances
i can think of where i've thought well
this person had a better argument but
the public seems convinced by someone
else
probably just because the other person
was more famous or they had more
attention or they were more
rhetorically flashy or what have you
yeah
i i mean i i agree i think that like
when it comes to
this question of uh i mean of course
it's a fantasy that if people have more
information more opportunities to debate
they're gonna
the best argument's gonna win the day i
mean there's so many factors
but i guess i would still say that it's
certainly better than the alternative
right because the alternative would be
that some centralized power is
controlling the narrative
so like it's not so much for me it's not
so much that oh like if we have
that i believe in this fantasy like oh
if there's free debate then
we're gonna have the best ideas like no
of course not like human beings are
fallible
and idiots and there's a lot of 20 20
year olds who are stupid as we talked
about last
podcast right and it's literally dude
there's way too many 20 year olds
way too many exactly so it's just like
people are stupid and they're not and
then when the 20 year olds get
when they get horny then they just start
watching jordan peterson on youtube
so so the point like so obviously i
don't believe in that fantasy but to me
it's just it's not about that it's not
about whether that's
plausible or not it's more about what's
the alternative and the alternative
seems worse to me yeah
which is presumably that you have
something controlling
debates and that just seems obviously
worse
no i completely agree with you right i
mean the notion that there'd be some
state committee or academic committee
even right that adjudicated what is
worthy of hearing
and what is not worthy of humoring seems
really frightening to me right
uh and pretty reprehensible
to me that's the only end of uh a
manifesto like this
like they just want everyone to read it
and go oh yeah if we
if we stop canceling people then the
better ideas will come forward
or you're saying okay let's get an
apparatus in here to make sure that
people are defended from
being fired by westjet for being racist
or whatever
well which is exactly why this demon is
like kind of lacking a little bit
because
it's just lacking a little bit because
it maybe is a it does buy into too much
a bit of that fantasy
uh because i certainly doubt that
anybody on this list would would support
some centralized committee like making
sure that people don't get fired for
we can look forward to next week and
kind of what i had prepared for talking
about today and that's
about power people think that power is
this
you know floating miasma
of of some something that one group has
and that one person doesn't have
but the only possible time this is like
foucault's main insight
the only time you have power is in very
particular
interactions that sort of develop into a
large pattern or an institution
so saying something like this is
useless in my opinion there's there's no
there's no
prescription for changing any particular
mechanism anything that brings power
about
they're whining about the power of the
twitter mob and there's only one way to
curtail
the power of the twitter mob and that
would be legislation
do you think that's the only way well
unless twitter's gonna start batting
people but that would be
directly opposed diametrically opposed
to twitter's interest well
the tides of opinion do change from time
to time like i think
this is but you're right this alone does
nothing but
i don't know yeah and i should say there
is an irony
implicit within the letter itself right
which is that a lot of the people
who signed it also made sure that they
included their
academic credentials or other
designations uh professional expertise
right
they didn't just rely on the substance
of what they were saying to make their
case for them what they're essentially
saying is
we're important people here's why we're
important
and this means that you should take what
we're saying to have some kind of
authority
right right well we could we can't
really we can't really decide whether
they decided
to include those right it might have
been the well
then harpers did right i mean i don't
have a problem with that right but it
does speak to the kind of pecoin point
that you're making right which is that
you know it's very difficult to
extricate the conditions of power from
any kind of discourse right which is why
i also think
you know while we should certainly
emphasize the importance of rational
communication and dialogue
we should always be aware that there are
many different ways in which
communication and dialogue and reason
can be distorted
by power by ideology and all that other
kind of nasty stuff that we talk about
i'm also curious reading the names on
this list you know i was one i was
thinking to myself
there are definitely some people who
would have signed this whose names
aren't on here and i wonder if that's
intentional right like because they do
for example jordan peterson
right like yeah so like i'll bet you
that was an intentional it's like we
don't want his name on here or i don't
know sam harris maybe i actually i
didn't actually check hard enough to see
if he wasn't on there but
i would imagine there's certain names
that are maybe that they don't want to
be associated with and they're like yeah
let's not even offer
those people to sign it yeah the the
most outspoken
people whose brand is only this thing
are not included on here because they
don't like that their brand is only that
thing
exactly exactly exactly no that's a
really good observation
yeah i mean really coleman hughes is
probably the one who's closest
associated with that since
i'm most closely associated with that
since his primary thing is writing for
colette and i think he's had a
cinder right think tank right now yeah
but yeah
i can't imagine that noam chomsky or
gisela carnell or samuel moyne
would really want to align themselves
with those kind of idw types
exactly so like yeah like obviously like
ben shapiro's not on here and i'm sure
he would have signed and i'm sure dave
rubin would have signed it i'm sure all
those people would have signed this
[ __ ] you're probably gonna get on stamp
fan mall and you decided yeah probably
yeah
but that really speaks to what's
actually being said here you know
the subtext and the subtext is really a
defense of their very particular
class interest in terms of this literati
intelligentsia class
and what they see is normal and their
normal is being solicited and their
opinions being
sought out which is also just blatant
self-interest
and i don't know if you could call that
conservative i guess it's sort of
conservative in the sense that they're
trying to
return to normalcy but this is no no no
but i think you're right i think it is
appealing to some sort of
like no like norm of maybe like in some
ways it to me it's almost like let's
you know not forget the values of you
know berkeley in 1968
or something like that you know the the
the like the like yeah open debate and
and challenging authority with debates
yeah last week
we talked our last time that we talked
uh victor
we i brought up alan bloom the closing
of the american mind so this
sounds exactly like his chapter because
he's freaking out about
black activists at uh university of
chicago in the 60s
like in the 60s this was although
although although alan bloom has an
agenda
which is not one necessarily debate his
son francis
fukuyama is on here no it's the other
way oh yeah his son yeah his son is on
here yeah
yeah yeah no but i mean
this is the one problem that i had with
the article right and i think we all
kind of agree that
you know freedom of speech open dialogue
opinion
trying to make rational arguments all
that's extremely important right
and you know to a certain extent we're
all committed liberals that way
the problem that i had with
i mean liberal in the broad sense not
necessarily liberal in the sense that
you support x y or z policy right
but you know but what i meant what i
think is problematic with this is that
if you're going to try to make the
argument that we need to
maintain a tradition of liberal
open-mindedness and dialogue and
a robust public sphere then that's fine
but then you should also try to engage
in
in-depth analysis of why a lot of those
mores aren't appealing to people any
longer
and there are a huge number of
dimensions to that that critical theory
to come back to the theme of this
podcast
can actually open up for you and what i
find problematic about a lot of these
people not all of them because i think
nomtrowski drew silicon now samuel moyne
all the good work on this thing but a
lot of the authors that i see there just
don't even bother doing that they're
just like well
we should maintain this norm of liberal
openness and nothing has really changed
since the 19th century
people communicate more or less the same
way that they used to
and if we just got back to what worked
for timeless centuries then everything
would be hunky-dory
and my kind of argument is well no times
have changed
and if you want to talk about
maintaining liberal norms then you also
need to talk about how to rejuvenate
them
and make them relevant in a digital era
right where there are new forms of power
that interfere with communication yeah i
think that's the material analysis here
is this is all
a reaction to media technology
because all all other modes of
communication
are now media technology right if you
write a if you're at a book you're
tweeting excerpts and tweeting the title
and if you write an article you have to
tweet to it you have to link to it
um the only way to be published at all
is to do it through
uh these digital media yeah yeah
like i almost want to invoke adorno here
right uh
no steven pinker is one of the
signatories to this letter right and
he's famous for his
endorsement of enlightenment reason and
how things are always getting better and
he says i can't understand why people
are rejecting the enlightenment on mass
it seems like a return to unreason
and i think we have to insist here on
the adornian point which is that no you
know
uh reason has or enlightenment reason
liberal reason as it was articulated in
the 19th century
as pretty serious problems inherent
within it and that doesn't mean we need
to reject it but it means that we need
to look at what those problems are
seriously and
in depth uh and then try to find a way
to reconstruct and rejuvenate them for
the 21st century
rather than just by saying saying well
things were great back then why don't we
just
return to the way things were right
which is a [ __ ]
brilliant point i think we should bring
that up uh
pretty early next next time and
especially when born is here because
adorno's
i don't know heart farmer's dialectic is
basically
blaming hegel more or less but you know
can't hegel
for the unreason of the enlightenment
but this is
this is really my area of critical
theory and i think eric's who's not here
but
pointing out those internal
contradictions
that maintain a whole normative system
and this is an argument this
article is an argument to maintain
normalcy
a normalcy which happens to be
benefiting them i don't want to say
we should dismiss it because it's
hypocritical yeah but this normalcy is
benefiting them
so it's in their self-interest to defend
it yeah right
right take somebody like take somebody
like habermas or max or not max
or horkheimer uh or axel honeth right
any of these people
who are really about uh you know
renewing communication and so on and
renewing reason and rejuvenating it
in the 20th and 21st century right none
of them would just say like
pills talking about right well what we
need is return to normalcy and if we
just go back to the enlightenment
everything will be fine right which
chomsky is also sometimes applause right
what they say is the enlightenment had
some seriously shitty problems inherent
within it
there was an emancipatory kernel to this
idea of reason
uh as a liberating force but the project
is not completed yet because
the material conditions and the cultural
conditions in which we live
are always going to warp reason uh
and dialogue in ways that aren't
beneficial
right and i just don't i just sometimes
find that
a lot of these analyses don't really try
to tackle any
of that right they just have this kind
of nostalgic
vision of what life was like back then
well i mean i i just
echo a lot of what you guys are saying i
don't like i don't really have all that
much to add
other than like i think it's it's
certainly
like a debate that that like continues
to frustrate
just because i think but like in some
ways the extremes of both sides
of the like so-called wokeness versus
non-wokeness debate are so loud
so like everything we've been saying
yeah it's just that's frustrating
because they're the loudest
and both of them kind of distort the
reality of what's actually happening and
make it seem
like a lot more of a severe situation
than maybe i think it is
even though like as i could as an
academic myself i would say
uh it probably maybe seems the most real
uh to people who are actually in
academia because that's still where it
comes up
more often maybe you guys would disagree
but i feel like that's where it seems
most real
potentially sir can i ask you something
victor this is something actually i
think we should all address
what do we think is a good model for
reason dialogue and open debate
uh and let's not say this podcast or the
three of us right you know
is there somebody out there we could
point to like who does open
reasonable interesting debate about
complicated issues as well
sorry my internet cut out for a second
there i
no no i said who can we think of a model
outside of
this you are my model matt i would never
i would never go talk to those people
ever
well thanks i appreciate that but no
outside of this can we point to someone
of prominence right that dialogues and
presents
constructive arguments about what's
going on doesn't kind of issue
complexity
and kind of serve as a model for how to
engage in a reasonable bait in the 21st
century yeah i mean
that's me and it's a really good
question it's a really good question i
mean i agree i certainly agree with
pills that you do you certainly do a
good job
um thanks but yeah i mean who who's
thinking
is the famous one that i i don't really
disagree with
most of what he says i agree i think
he's i don't think he censors himself
for it although he although like the
reason oh god [ __ ]
um someone did did you
did you ask that question because you
have someone in mind
i know actually i was going to say jesus
as well so you beat me to that right
i mean i think he does a really good job
uh
bringing things down to earth and he
does absolutely 100 engage with his
political opponents
pretty much engages with everybody right
uh my internet just keeps on cutting out
here for a second or something but i'm
back
yeah we're we're still in storm and
storm zone
i guess we're still inside yeah so yeah
so matt actually agreed and said gj
yeah jj is good although the one thing
that is that's like could be sometimes
frustrating about him is he might like
refuse which
also may be a good thing about him
actually he'll kind of refuse to argue
the point
yeah but like you you've seen thousands
of times how futile it is
to argue the point especially especially
against
you know that br that brand of
intellectual dad web
people
i think we should talk about this again
we were prepared for it
so we didn't have any like interesting
quips or actually
theoretical background to bring it i
should speak for myself i didn't
know we were going to talk about that
it's an interesting topic to me
it doesn't really matter all that much
i'd rather create
spaces for speaking rather than complain
about the spaces
that i have to talk to people i don't
like in
um maybe your opinion will change after
we get cancelled
i wouldn't even know if we got cancelled
though like
i don't know i don't have twitter
notifications sound that's true
uh matt would we have to protect i guess
the only circumstance when it would
actually matter is if somehow this
podcast got big enough or we had paid
sponsors
and then we started losing sponsors
because people like
rallied them what do we say that's
offensive i don't think we say anything
this event so i'm just saying you never
know times are changing
like if we i don't if we got cancelled
for something that we said so far
i i would be shocked because we we laugh
at people it's like kind of uh
like sort of absurdity and they're like
sometimes we'll laugh at certain groups
as like irrationality or
unreasonableness i don't know i guess
yeah
20 year olds yeah i mean i think
canceled by 20 year olds
i think the only condition which would
happen is honestly like uh kind of like
a james gun scenario somebody dragged
out
dragged up something we said back in the
day and use that to try to hit his
head with right i have been on twitter
for 10 years
and before i started posting you're
gonna have to before i started posting
youtube videos i had like
five tweets it was one tweet every two
years average
yeah anyway uh we hope you don't get
canceled matt we're gonna do our
our best to uh defend you outside since
you actually have a job too
yeah well only for the first year then
once you get like
10-year track official then we can you
can say whatever you want so
there you go uh so uh this is
only the start of a discussion more to
come we're moving into a series of
on power as i've probably mentioned
twice already but we're
it's going to end up in marks because i
think we need to establish our position
on
marks because if we want to have a
position on the twitter
the twitter land everyone there has a
hot take on marx
and i think i think he might be a little
bit overrated and i think you might be
putting too much stock
into his relevance today not that he's
overrated for his own time
i would never say that yeah but i think
saying oh we can just
parallel one-to-one apply marxian ideas
into the conditions that we are
witnessing
nobody says that not even lenin said
that so
we're going to do marx cool with people
who know marx
better than i definitely better than me
oh yeah [ __ ]
but better than like 99.99 percent of
mark success it'll be useful
all right so here uh we'll say goodbye
from
matt our uh what did i call you again
you're an inquisitor
oh radical you're a left inquisitor
paladin
and of course the bard
thank you yes i think we should just do
you should do some lectures
and then we'll post them up as like
sleep aids who me
yeah just you just just reading or you
could just do reading just like read
i should read i should read marx's
capital
yeah or john stewart mail yeah just just
read it in yours
i don't know how to describe it your
base i could whisper i could do we could
do like an asmr
oh that's a hot search term on youtube
yeah i know yeah
we should do it we could put it up on
our second youtube channel
are you gonna are you gonna put that up
yet or what it'll happen
okay people are asking for it and you're
asking for it
most of all so it's a good idea i think
it's a good idea
cool that was fun kind of ad hoc but it
was fun
uh be careful for the lightning outside
if you're in the city
and matt be careful be careful of
america are you are you in america right
now
no i'm still in ottawa for a dollar oh
be careful of ottawa then
yeah you'll be here you wanna you don't
wanna you don't want too many people to
see you on the street in ottawa you
never know what's can happen yeah ottawa
is like the safest [ __ ] city in
the entire goddamn world
right like no i mean i mean lag around a
little bit too hard out there
for supporting their charity the charity
or they'll pull you into an alley
trying to bribe you you know offer to
hook up with a pedophile ring
there's any anything could happen in
there this would look
cool all right goodbye guys should we
start the rough stuff yeah
[Music]
you